هذا الرجل المترنح ليس احد المشردين الذين
يعيشون على حافه الطريق انه جندي مدرب في
ثاني اقوى جيش في العالم
منذ بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا شكلت الخسائر
البشريه الكبيره ضربه قاسيه وغير متوقعه
للجيش الروسي
معظم القتل الروس سقطوا خلال العمليات
القتاليه
لكن هناك نسبه ليست بالقليله سقطت لاسباب
اخرى
كل هذه الاسلحه والمعدات العسكريه
المتطوره تسعف بعض الجنود الروسي للنجاه
من الموت او الاسر في اوكرانيا الامر لا
يتعلق بقوه العدو او تفوق
بعامل اخر يحول اعطى الجنود في العالم
الى فرائس يسهر اصطيادها من قبل الخصوم
انه شرب الكحول
تقارير عده تحدثت عن انتشار الكحول بين
الجنود الروسي في اوكرانيا وان عددا منهم
يفرط في تناوله
في الاحوال العاديه يغيب الافراط في طاعات
الكحول صاحبه عن الوعي فما بالكم عندما
يكون ذلك في ساحه المعركه امام عدو يتحين
اي فرصه للانقضاض على خص
مه تقرير استخباراتي لوزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه قال ان القوات الروسيه تلحق
بنفسها الضرر نتيجه الشرب المفرط وسوء
التعامل مع الاسلحه وهذا ما اكدته قناه
محليه روسيه حيث قالت ان عددا مرتفعا
للغايه من الحوادث والجرائم والوفيات في
صفوف الجنود الروسي مرتبط بالكحول
ورغم معرفتها بالعون اشار التقرير الهم
القوات المسلحه الروسيه تتغاضى عن انتشار
الكحول بين جنوبها
تعلق موسكو على تلك التقارير
استهلاك الكحول يعد من الاسباب الرئيسيه
للخسائر غير القتاليه في صفوف القوات
الروسيه باوكرانيا الكثير من الجنود الروس
ماتوا متاثرين بجرعه كحول زائده
الاوكران استغلوا هذا الامر جيدا ففي
ابريل من العام الماضي نقل 500 جندي
روسيين الى المستشفيات بعد احتسائهم
مشروبا كحوليا ملغما بالسم عدمه لهم
مدنيون اوكرانيا
استخبارات وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه تقدر
اجمالي الخسائر البشريه الروسيه بين 175
الف جندي و200 الف فيما لم تنشر روسيا
احصاءات محدثه عن عدد الضحايا منذ خريف
عام 2022 عندما اعربت موسكو التعبئه
الجزئيه لثلاثمائه الف جندي احتياطي حينها
قال وزير الدفاع الروسي ان عدد القتل
الروس بلغ خمسه الاف جندي فقط
على مدار اكثر من عام لم تقف روح الحرب في
اوكرانيا ولا حتى لدقيقه واحده المعارك
العنيفه لا تزال مستمره
وضحايا من الجانبين بالالاف وكلا الطرفين
لن يوفر اي فرصه للانقضاض على الاخر
مساحه مشتعله كهذه من المؤكد ان اي
استهتار او تقصير من قبل الجنود
هو نتيجه الموتى لا محد
[موسيقى]